so let's start it Hadoop on Google cloud
platform first of all it's extremely
fast to set it up so if you know that if
you go to probably a IP company
sorry the IT department within your
company you'll end up with the question
I need a Hadoop cluster and it needs to
be this big and next up you get a
planning of five weeks or more just to
get started we need to investigate etc
so what I'm going to show you later on
is that it can be done in like 1/2
minutes that you have a cluster ready
for operations with your data
another thing is cloud Hadoop is most of
the time seen as something called
something like a low-level
infrastructure thing that is happening
within the cluster itself well actually
it's it's quite hard being a good data
engineer but what we want is that you
focus on your data and not necessarily
on the infrastructure level that's
something that we can manage for you and
most importantly you don't pay in front
upfront like thousands of dollars you
just start and you'll see that scaling
up scaling down is once something that's
very flexible and actually built-in in
the data product so if you go to if you
look at the landscape or the whole scope
of where we are today you can go from
from infrastructure to platform what
does it mean on one side you see
on-premise and that's actually how many
organizations are doing it they're
trying it out and yeah so at some moment
you have a vendor photo like cloud era
or another party which can help you in
that whole process there are some tools
like BD util which actually allows you
to do command-line activities and create
a cluster but if you want to have it
like manage but still have control on
everything what's happening in there
well data proc is your best friend and
actually the last three categories are
provided by the Google cloud platform so
let's take a peek under the hood of what
Google cloud platform I have a Google
Cloud Data Brock is
first of all you have to think in layers
the layer which is actually quite
important is first of all think of who's
interacting with the system then you
have the system and then you have the
ecosystem of all the things that are
connected to your to you Hadoop cluster
I'd like to think also in Hadoop cluster
because it's nothing else than that so
if you are used to working with your do
cluster yes you can if you want to do an
SSH to your do cluster and run some
Hadoop jobs yes you can but you have to
think in layers and the good part is you
have options you can always go like you
wanted to go or like to did it so far we
also provide some API switch actually
have something nifty in there because
yes I can start a job close my laptop go
home and see the job finished
so that's something that's quite
different with Hadoop jobs that you
probably have in your cluster now
another thing is that the Hadoop stack
that we have is of Apache big-top that's
actually like a collection of spark
Hadoop hive pick those tools that are
familiar doop stack itself on the other
side of course you have the data
processing part then you have the
analytics part and on analytics part you
see the people plug in lots of third
party tools like Jupiter presto Zeppelin
to depth cluster and that's actually how
we like to see that you start using it
so this is how cloud data proc is in the
end so if you're planning a pork a POC
there's one thing that's that's
happening I think and maybe the people
who just raised their hands can confirm
it that you start out with a Hadoop
cluster you say okay I have it then you
say okay now we need something special
spark by spark high pick everything on
top of it then all of a sudden your data
science say okay I'd like to you know
access the data and then they plug in
Jupiter notebook etc so the good part of
the Hadoop stack itself is that you can
augment that whole city
quite well it's built for integration
but on the other sites it becomes a
monolith in years and all of a sudden
people say okay you know it's running
I'm not going to touch it
and that's exactly why you have to think
not about lifting it to a new
environment but maybe you have to
rethink what you're using and maybe you
should start to figure out okay this is
a workaround and this is something I
really need and that's something we're
gonna see in a bit also so this is this
is what you see quite often happening
which is actually not a good thing so if
you look at the goals that people can
have it's yeah most of the times it's
about cost savings
how much do I save with it our advice is
don't go buy buy buy but look at the
whole experience of it price performance
in that context scaling elasticity so
multiple is to scale out is very easy if
you want to burst for just a couple of
minutes it's actually quite easy if you
don't have that capacity and you need it
at that moment you can just say it to
the system and then it will give it to
you back now I'm saying say it
unfortunately I don't ever how duped
them are with Google home device but
that would be really cool but that's for
the next time then for development
yeah the soap actually if you look at
this list you probably find one of the
reasons that you say okay that's the
reason why I would like to move forward
to something new because it's becoming
really expensive so another thing that
is something that you should start
figuring out for yourself because each
of the environments are different they
have a different need and that's
actually also out starts because it's
not about I have one cluster and
I'm gonna do everything with that most
of time that is the end result of what's
what's happening now with Hadoop in
production so what you have to figure
out for yourself is what open source
components am I using what is indeed
necessary and what is a workaround you
might you might find something that you
say ok I shouldn't have done it but now
I have a new option to start doing it
again but differently another thing is
the system characteristics so we can
natively supports H HBase which is also
very common in a Hadoop cluster HDFS of
course and many other protocols that are
quite known in the Google cloud but
again you have to figure out yourself
what is necessary for your environment
is it about SSDs is it the bubble you
know hard this is about cold storage is
a data that I access a lot yes or no
many characteristics that are you know
typical to your environment and also
about the timeline you quality of
capacity so you know it's very hard to
say now today I think I was one such
situation that people had to bring in
seriously server rack configure it and
you know try to do some calculations on
it or from data science but in the end
that's that's not where the value is
it's not the harder it's not the
software also it's about what you get
out of your data that is so common so so
particularly to this specific client so
that's why I would say another thing
that's very important is how do I get my
data into the system
all this runs around data right and
we're collecting quite a lot nowadays so
if you look at the storage options you
have a couple of them the Google Cloud
Storage which it which is an object
store so it has some some other
semantics HDFS some data proper system
disk so if you want to have performance
but if you want to go higher in that
context you can opt for SSDs another
thing is if you want to say ok fine
I don't want to manage my data at all
then something like BigTable cloud
BigTable comes in which in fact is an
HBase implementation so everything you
know from HBase can be reused in this
context also and if you really don't
want to worry about the underlying part
and want to use as many tools in the
keynote and bigquery which is no-ops
data warehouse solution that Google
provides in the cloud where you can do
petabytes kill queries in like minutes
and it's becoming really more important
because we have some customers that are
generating petabytes of data a day so
then bigquery might be another solution
to look at for storage of course if you
look at a time line it's some people use
the storage for archiving or for backup
recovery the nice part is if you do if
you try to put it in these storage
options given an option to run ad-hoc
queries if you want because you have
that environment ready you don't have to
replicate a lot so that that might be
another thing to think about okay if you
look at so the Google Cloud connector is
in fact one of the cornerstones of the
whole implementation if you're gonna go
Google Cloud why because first of all
you have to get get your data in I'm
gonna show you a couple of options that
you have to get your data into the
system but first of all GSF GC s and
HDFS are implementations that are you
know enter interoperable you can quite
easily implement the access to your
files actually by changing the protocols
to for example GS colon slash slash
there is a difference though HDFS is has
a different semantics and I mentioned in
a moment ago the semantics I mean to say
that we have something called in HDFS we
have something called directories cloud
storage doesn't have that context the
nice part is is that
the world of Hadoop is starting to
understand that whole concept of not
having directories because if you look
at it in a different from a different
angle it might not make sense anymore
because we're doing like unstructured
data all over the place there is a pro
and a con on that of course because we
get the fact that we don't have
directories and other things that are
different then HDFS has to do with the
fact that we want to have high
availability so it's it's up to you
there are ways to still do it anyhow but
for example if you have files that that
are on which data is added so they
append it they append data to it then
you might have to look into the native
HDFS F implementation on Google Cloud
Storage of Google Cloud so Indian their
pros and cons but the most important
part is that you do realize that you
have options you have options to move
forward also so getting data in your
system can be done in two ways
you have the push based version versus
the pull based version what does it mean
so there's tooling on the command line
which you can say distribute copy and
all my files are pumped into the cloud
storage that's just a command line tool
that you can do then you use your
internet gateway and that's it that's
the easiest way to go forward but you
can of course imagine that a custom say
well no that's too leaky although it's
over HTTPS etc I still want to have with
my firewall rules with my routing
information I want to have access sorry
I want to provide my data to the cloud
environment so for that Google provides
a Google cloud VPN gateway which allows
you to create a private sub network
within the Google cloud platform which
fits your network needs for a firewall
and actually creates a bridge between
the cloud environment and your
environment the most interesting part is
is that you can query from both
environments now
you can't start varying from the cloud
environment because it's like a bridge
you can acquire you own the on-premise
situation depending on the firewall
rules but also from the other side you
just can query the data that's stored in
Google Cloud that's make sense so there
are a couple of options that you have
here
so another result of doing all these
migrations and thinking forward and of
course if you have paying you try to fix
it is to think about some bigger
architectural context concepts so one of
the most important things is in cloud
data proc is the way we think about it
is if people started clustered now the
first question that you get is how much
data are you gonna store so people start
ramping up hardest and saying okay I
want so much petabytes of data for
artists available we in cloud think
differently on this context because this
concept which is called in Hadoop which
is called bin packing and data locality
both things are very important when you
start to implement your when you start
to implement your Hadoop cluster on
premise or in an in an hosted
environment but the most important part
is that if you start doing that you're
adding complexity to your cluster
because managing that part is it's what
I just meant what I mentioned in the
beginning is it's going to create
overheads and your operations and it's
gonna make it more complex the cool part
of this also is it the Hadoop cluster
with separate storage supports bin
packing out of the box and data locality
is that something you don't even have
think about because the Google Cloud can
make sure that the data is close to you
depending on how you start your cluster
so if you do this there's another note
that is very important so if you defy
compute and storage if you divide those
two you can start thinking in different
concepts now because
if I said if initially you said that the
computation power of sorry the
computation hours were like 10,000
10,000 hours - for example - data
analysis part you now can say okay so
that was one hour 10,000 CPUs see CPUs
and now you can say okay give me 20,000
see CPUs and and a half an hour I have
my data processed or give me 100 free
CEUs and hundred hours of processing
that's up to you
the good part is you have the freedom in
the end because in the end the total
cost of all those three options are the
same if you do ten thousand one hour
twenty thousand thousand hour or ten 400
in hundred hours
the cost for the Google cloud platform
is the same so now you see that you can
process the same kind of information and
less time because you can burst and
allocate quite some CPUs because you
make the distinction between storage and
compute another very nice thing and I
notice it in my demo also when I was
preparing this is the cost having true
preemptable VMs what our preemptable
seems so who of you are in the DevOps
area who are building and creating VMs
maybe in your build process so
preemptable VMs are exactly meant for
those kind of situations because what
happens is that if you build you need
you run a test and then you kill the VM
again right so normally and normally you
would buy a contract or sign for a year
or have an hourly billing situation so
and even if you use it like 10 minutes
so preemptable films are first of all
minute minute based billing and another
thing is they like 20 percent of the
price of an original fee and because we
know you're gonna throw it away in a and
and that's another thing if you don't
throw it away
Google has the right to reclaim that
capacity because if you're not doing
anything with it and it's not meant to
live long in your cluster
and that's actually the nicest part of
Google cloud data prod as fast as you
bring it up like in 1/2 minutes even
faster you can break it down and that's
actually quite cool and it saves quite
some money because it's each of the
films that we have is like 20% of the
cost of an original VM and I calculated
the simple VM it's like one dollar a day
and it's my 20 cents sorry it's one
dollar per hour more or less and it will
become like 20 cents per hour another
thing that the Google Cloud supports is
that you if you have a workload like on
that side which is full you might notice
that you not using the full capacity and
that's the thing right we have a
shortage of DRAM and art rare and stuff
so and it's gonna cost you if you start
using quite large clusters which in
incidentally using it that's gonna cost
you quite some money so what you can do
here and that's actually quite a nice
feature of google cloud we have right
sizing in place so you can even say I
want 3 CPUs instead of 4 with a strange
amount of gigabytes the craziest
configuration is possible in this
context another thing is that if you use
the Google cloud you'll you you'll also
notice that we're gonna recommend you at
some moment because we notice that
you're not using the full capacity and
we'd like to advise you on that because
you're gonna get a cost saving marker
also in your console and another thing
is don't make just one cluster to do
everything
think about your clusters because
because you separate a compute power
from storage you can now think about
doing the ETL stuff in a different
cluster than your machine learning stuff
then you're - and lettings then business
reporting also quite big but as you guys
probably already know that machine
learning consumes quite some power
especially compute power and for that
you can create a different workload you
can create a different cluster or a
different configuration with like lots
of
use GPUs GPUs maybe and like low on
memory maybe so
this is also not something to think
about when you start moving forward and
of course we can kill the surface quite
fast so start if you use it then you say
okay drop it and throw it away but it's
something called a semi long-lived
cluster and actually that's very
interesting so consider this following
situation I have to keep track all the
time
consider the following situation that
you have your cluster it's production
it's version 1 whatever and but Hadoop
has a new release coming up which is 10x
faster or maybe has the whole complexity
that you have to lean like five lines
reduces it to one command the nice part
is you can start doing load balancing
between and canary testing for those who
know that term that's about you know
trying the latest greatest but not
breaking your whole production you can
even so you can create pluses with the
newest version and make it part of your
production process you can even start
testing will it work for me will it help
me will it create value in the end so we
have many so you can start creating
clusters in a group and that acts as one
and just test it with your data see if
it works
and at some moment you could say I'm
upgrading all my closest to death
version that's actually like four lines
of four clicks that's really impressive
if you see here in the debt in action so
we want to see things in action so let's
go for it
I have some commands here so first of
all do mention if it's not readable this
is readable right
so instead of typing all the commands I
have your cheat sheet so first of all
what you see here is that I'm creating
an it's a race sorry I'm doing a jig
cloud data proc close to create roguish
demo one with number of workers of 5
I added some properties we'll see what
that's what it actually is and I added
also attack with my name on it so at
this moment it's creating a cluster for
me so in the Google Cloud console you
can see that it's already starting
creating and console sorry a plus for me
with five workers it's busy doing that
but while it's creating my cluster I can
also say create another cluster so demo
- it's in Europe West yeah but not in a
crate another closet thing so now a
second cluster is being created I also
can say as mentioned in the beginning I
can also dive into creating another
cluster let's call it
three and now I want to use the latest
greatest of Hadoop so we have a couple
of image versions and this is a previous
version of Hadoop to rotate so you can
already start it and I said create thing
now you see that three classes are being
created at this moment and hopefully
within a couple of seconds you see an
output in this context that's it so n
I'm not sure if it's feasible but here
you can see it and one minute 39 seconds
it created a cluster in US central so
the latency is I think part of why it's
not beneath the 130 so now we have a
cluster and in the meanwhile the other
clusters will be coming life also so
what I can do the next step is show you
a native console so so the people who
are familiar with Hadoop probably know
this interface also so what I have to do
now is create a tunnel to my cluster
so I'm creating a tunnel that's it I'm
starting Chrome let's hear this
I'm starting Chrome with specifics for
using the socket at the proxy that is
required for doing this kind of
connection and if I go to HTTP request
demo one and the master on 8080 cluster
yes there M so this is the console that
most of the people who work with Hadoop
know you have it's exactly the same kind
of server we're not adding anything to
it it's just be managing to make sure
that you can use it so this is another
cluster and you can see in this one that
this is the 273 release right so now so
chrome is giving me errors clear then
the next step is okay say I want to do
native ado so that that that's the thing
I was used to
so what I'm what I do now is I'm gonna
do a local SSH
so I'm doing an SSH to the command line
of my cluster itself in a minute I'm
there
yep and what so now I'm in the US
central cluster environment I can say
Hadoop jar and then where's the lying
user lip
let's see
Hadoop MapReduce
let's see are you guys familiar with
Terrigen ever heard of it telogen yeah
okay this one telogen is and like a
rapper - it's a reference set of data
that you can sort and that's quite
interesting to do some measurements on
it Map Reduce examples doc jar Terrigen
say I want to have this and I'm gonna
create it
am i next hamster
Amsterdam
tada
yeah
temple
so what's doing now it's it's actually
doing and Hadoop job on my cluster at
this moment and it's creating data it's
creating a lots of data so I think this
is a hundred megabyte of data in this
Google Cloud storage location so another
thing that you always have is Google
Cloud storage so if i refresh it here so
what we're looking at is this Google
Cloud storage user interface and files
are being created at this moment so
that's the thing that's happening on the
cluster and an interesting part is is
that in the here this one if i refresh
this one I can see that
needing some time here
okay it will be there in a moment but
then you can see like the default flow
of all the processes that are running
this is still native Hadoop you're not
doing something specially so another way
to run jobs because the the thing is
that if I this one is finished
unfortunately I can control see it and
then I'm lost right then I have to
restart the job again but what we can do
here also is I can fire up cloud data
Pro project a verse or a job on my
cluster and this might be a long
statement but what it's doing it's it's
firing off a job it's firing off so what
you do is will cloud data probes submit
Hadoop and then the same MapReduce
example that you saw a moment ago only I
didn't provided parameters the reason
why I did that is to see this error log
because I did it on purpose it's not
demo error by the way hopefully nothing
will be coming up also but what you see
now is that okay I have an error so I
have to fix it so the next step is to
fix this statement and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna say
we're going to say Terrigen like we just
did a moment ago and then I can say it
on the Google Cloud storage
the next Amsterdam bucket create the
Terrigen them to give me something
yep so now it's it's submitting a job
and that's actually very cool submitting
a job in Google data Prague is like fun
because everything that everybody does
with your system you can record it it
will be recorded actually and what I can
do now is while it's running I can go to
the cloud console and have a look at my
clusters I see that jobs are being fired
so I had two wrong jobs apparently I can
see the log and one is running at this
moment so another thing to do is if I
take control see I'm not losing the job
because what I can do is I can say gee
cloud data Park jobs wait and then I
take the the job ID go see it
and what they will do is reconnect to
the stream that is being generated by
the output and in the end I'm finished
so that's something that you can get you
can start to job close your left or go
home and then you'll still be executing
anyhow in the background so another
thing that I would like to show you and
I still have time yeah nice is a thing
called a stack driver so stuck driver is
like our monitoring tools over cloud
environments if you want to so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to create a
group here called rakesh demo demo life
and I'm gonna add a tag and mi4 one of
my first statements that's here I use
the tag this so the tag is actually
quite interesting because now you can
combine several clusters together and
have a dashboard on all the classes in
one go although they're totally
independent totally not related maybe
even but you can see the complete
performance of your of your clusters
that you're running
have criteria dying safe group nope this
one can go save group
so instead rival the very interesting
part is within
stackdriver group you can create
dashboards and that's what is actually
quite straightforward because you can
say for example the let's see the
inbound traffic
it's a bit slow I don't know why but
you see II
yeah so we have the network imbalance we
make a stack area and we filter on group
where the group value is equal to my
demo and then I say safe and what I can
do is now on-the-fly add charts on the
cluster itself this is something that is
very powerful which allows you to indeed
have now a few of all your classes
running at the same time of course we
have something similar also in the
cluster environment where if you click
on a cluster you can see the CPU
utilization this are apparently the jobs
that I tried a moment ago Network by its
capacities etc it's all everything that
you can see but the biggest different
with stack graph is that you can see it
in one go you can make a dashboard out
of it and show it everywhere so I think
it's time to do something really beefy
so what I did before this demo I created
the Terrigen a hundred gigabyte of
sorting data and I would like to have my
loop cluster to work on it so yeah so
let's go back to this one so this is the
segment it's the same thing the only
thing is that we're doing definitely is
now we doing terror sort so that's the
sorting algorithm it's for benchmarking
so we can see what the performance is of
that and I will do it on a hundred
gigabyte of data so I submit the job
and what you see now is that it's you
know it's done of gigabyte of data it's
not very easy to do that it's gonna cost
some time so what I'm waiting for now is
to see the percentages go up and if you
see it in a bit so it's gonna be like
every 20 seconds it's gonna do 1% which
is not that fast right and I already
created my clothes so what to do now so
what you can do is so while this one is
doing like say about 20 seconds more or
less what we can do now is we can go
back to the cluster go into the
configuration and this is this is the
easiest thing I've ever seen
it's a edit that's it save 40 I want to
have 40 working out so what's happened
what happens now is the request is
submitted
it's not cancelled yes they are
cancellation because I didn't have
enough quota but now my cluster is
creating 40 cm instances immediately and
a moment they are available and managed
the cloud the calculation that is
happening will start using it so that's
it's spanning from 5 workers immediately
to 40 workers and hopefully the result
in the mid in a bit is that you will see
that this job will go faster and faster
I'll leave it open in the background so
yeah another thing that is very
interesting to show in in stag life
itself is if you look at
something called for crate and a memory
and this is actually let me stick to
memory only memory used is a line chart
filter group
safe
so the interesting part is and if i zoom
in a bit here you you can now see which
VM sorry it's visible you can now see
which VM is taking like lots of memories
is taking up all the memory and what
you'll see at the moment is if all the
classes come together and the 40 plus 30
40 40 PMS are available then you see
them all spiking also so actually you
can see where there's a bottleneck in
your framework and you can say oh good
it might be time to add some memory or
extra compute power so that's that's
actually quite impressive also and yeah
oh yeah another thing that I totally
forgot but it's very important
so I created a cluster which was in a
different preview version so what I can
do now here is I can go to tree that's
my third cluster that I created and if
the network is working yes it is it's
actually quite slow
I'll end up in that cluster which is
apparently also running also about
you can imagine that yesterday the demo
was fast but if it's there what I'm
showing here is that I'm actually using
another version of Hadoop which is
version 2.8 snapshot which is available
which is made available by Google for
you and we take the latest snapshot each
day so that allows you to start you know
do the canary testing part so if all the
things are done and you say okay it's
fine my job is going faster now instead
of just every 20 seconds it's now every
2 seconds or something like that you can
say okay fine kill my clusters so the
killing a cluster or removing the
cluster can be done and that's something
I would like definitely to share with
you guys is that if you have a cluster
or sir if you say create cluster there
is always a rest interface available for
that why is this important because
people found out that we need
orchestration tools like airflow and
Luigi to make sure that they can
interact with these kind of clusters and
manage it so for all the actions that
you've seen that have Dubey nuances
today you can find an untold another
sorry the rest version of that going
forward so deleting a cluster is like
selecting it throwing it away bang
that's it and that's also everything
that I would like to show in this demo
see you have 2 minutes so managing
clusters what we did is we showed that
it can go into the true raw clients or
to the user interface of cloud data
product create clusters jobs and
operations we have low-level API service
jobs api's all of them we don't want to
frustrate you right so if you was used
to do jobs go ahead make a day I start
using Hadoop but if you want to use a
bit more sophisticated approach where
jobs are not killed because you're close
lepto or because there was a network
outage then these are other ways to go
forward to everything is rest based all
the calls that are made with the g-cloud
command can be done through rest
updating down scaling and up scaling can
be done through the edit button also
through rest if you want to logging and
monitoring is part of the platform and
even if you have multiple clusters in a
big environment which is gonna happen
anyhow you can do it so putting it all
together reference architecture for
burst loads is use the internet gateway
and then we're gonna fire off in the
cloud we use it and we throw it away and
hybrid type approach is possible where
you use a VPN gateway to talk and bring
data back and forth and do your job
wherever you want to especially if the
data is not necessarily allowed to be in
the cloud and you can go go full cloud
native which in the long run will help
you with canary testing with upgrading
never I would never accept an argument
that says so you know it's been running
for two years let's stick let's keep it
let's not touch it in this case you can
start canary testing immediately and say
ok part of my workload is going to go to
that new other cluster and we'll see if
there's a performance gain in depth so
if you want to get started with cloud
data proc these are the links story
tools are available this code sample is
can be made available so find me if you
want to dive into this kind of context
and yeah for documentation can find
quite a bit I did my first presentation
on data broke one and a half years ago
this is more or less the same product
with lots of extra features on top of it
and since then so since the launch like
one out of years ago there's lots of
contents also to be found on Stack
Overflow follow the discussions and find
us in support and for the rest I'd like
to thank you for your time and patience
thank you very much
you